el presidente pedro castillo afirma que
el toque de queda es para proteger la
integridad y la seguridad de las
personas y garantizar los derechos
fundamentales de los ciudadanos diversos
sectores del país critican que el
mandatario solamente haya tomado el
toque de queda para lima y callao y no
para las otras regiones del perú donde
se han producido saqueos y demás actos
vandálicos el decreto de urgencia
autoriza solamente la movilización de
trabajadores del sector salud alimentos
seguridad y telecomunicaciones la
presidenta del congreso maría del carmen
alba ha criticado que el mandatario no
haya incluido al parlamento en la nómina
y ha advertido que pedro que ha sido no
puede impedir el funcionamiento del
poder legislativo francisco le preguntó
entonces cómo amanece limay qué
reacciones se han producido en estas
últimas horas
bueno el presidente pedro castillo dio
su mensaje pasada a las 11 y 30 de la
noche no todos lo vieron y es por eso
que muchos trabajadores recién se
enteraron del toque que da esta
madrugada cuando acudieron a los
paraderos de autobuses para dirigirse a
sus centros de labores como está la
medida de excepción no circulan los
autobuses ni tampoco los taxis entonces
esto creó malestar en los ciudadanos la
defensoría del pueblo por su parte ha
exigido al presidente pedro castillo que
ese es el toque de queda porque señala
que es inconstitucional y no está
debidamente justificada en la medida